i feel like you know i feel like we're
kind of getting to the point where like
you know
i think 15 20 years from now just like
everyone's gonna be [ __ ] everybody
like yeah i feel like it's going there
yo i know man gay boys that that was
like [ __ ] girls i know matt like a
lot of a lot of [ __ ] that i talk to
like got kids um from like you know
previous relationships yeah being in
high school and still being down low and
still [ __ ] girls that kind of like
you know
hey i'm not gay like so i don't talk to
i don't talk to a
few [ __ ] they got kids that's
interesting their kids be like 9 10
years old
like they was [ __ ] you know girls in
high school girls get pregnant you know
[ __ ] got kids
how do you feel like because i feel like
we've we've had a couple of teaching
moments in the last year in terms of
just like
you know what happened with the baby
last year running loud like i feel like
uh sometimes
we're very quick to like [ __ ] on
somebody as opposed to like trying to
like
teach them this new castle culture or
cancer culture [ __ ] it's like
trolling this is a trend now so now the
world is different back then you had to
like like
you you wasn't making no blogs like we
had to reach it in magazines or you know
what i'm saying or [ __ ] myspace my
sister it was hard now now you get on in
there and customize your eyes back out
we on the shade room in three in three
seconds and three seconds or you could
retweet my picture and say something say
something some dumb [ __ ] or some bible
[ __ ] it go viral you all over the blog
so now people feeling like you know what
i'm saying not to say that fans
understand but just something like
they're important yeah like so they're
like oh [ __ ] i know i could everyone
feel like they got an opinion that's
better yeah i feel like y'all got
leverage like people like to feel like
they got you by the bars like oh you
said this say sorry
never let's see i'm using them on you
can't never come back outside like suck
a dick like [ __ ] are y'all talking about
literally literally like you know it's
like because people are not doing things
now because they actually care people
are doing things now because like cause
they're gonna get attention they're
gonna get attention like i got the top
comment or oh a hundred people say it
down like it's blue hat so we don't [ __ ]
with the blue head cuz 100 people said
it in the comments we're just gonna be
bandwagoners i also feel like with a lot
of the cancer culture [ __ ] like just in
general like most of the time it's like
a very small amount of people who are on
twitter dumb people like when you meet
people in real life i swear to god i
just said this it's like yo most real
people don't give a [ __ ] about it
it's in the internet when you meet
people in real life you'll be like i'll
be like well where's all the
[ __ ] there hey because people
they try to come at you for old tweets
yeah which was crazy they do that to
everybody everybody and it's like my
thing is my thing is i'm not a i'm a
realistic person i'm not a fake person
yeah like everybody now is like
oh my god i can't believe you said this
in 2011 bro if you wasn't famous if the
same people that's finding our own
sweets if they wasn't famous let's go
and your twitter and see what the [ __ ]
was you saying also what are you doing
with your life where you're digging
through someone's timeline back to two
you know when they do it they do it when
you're about to reach like some type of
accomplishment or something and that's
why i said people now know that i could
go dig up a tweet and i could make this
go viral and i could have you would be
in the laughingstock or the talk of the
whole world right now because we people
it's it's set up to now where like
[ __ ] got you by the balls like oh i
could go find his old tweet saying we
he's gonna get cancelled we're gonna and
he's gonna have to sit down and
apologize like they feel like they got
some kind of power over you now so it's
not it's people's drugs it's like they
get a dopamine hit yeah when they come
for people and it works and it works and
it's like but you know you have so many
people in the world like
bro somebody said [ __ ]
10 years ago that's why i love that
cardi b suit i mean listen i don't know
that blogger you know what i'm saying
but i love the fact that
cardi b won that lawsuit yeah because
that blogger was saying some [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah and it's like yo hopefully this
kind of helps correct and people you
know people believe love the negative
narrative of things that's what's best
that's what's more better or fun to
believe from them so when you're saying
wow [ __ ] about people or like you know
what i'm saying even when people are
digging up these old tweets
and
we do these pr apologies that your
neighbor make you do of course and all
that guess what people still say
[ __ ] you will believe you of course all
right oh we don't care you you said that
you meant it
so just be like whatever but i go
through comments and i see those people
the logical people that everybody is
like
bro somebody said some [ __ ] 10 years ago
who gives a [ __ ] 10 years ago was when
you had to have a bible tweet
well also 10 years ago getting canceled
wasn't the thing it wasn't a thing it
was like i'm gonna just say some ill
[ __ ] yo you got you got on twitter and
talk [ __ ] you got on twitter you watch
award shows or you watch whatever the
[ __ ] and you've just said wow crazy [ __ ]
because back then you really had to have
a good tweet well you know what that
means it's crazy too because they just
tried to do that with gloria and i was
like yo like she just signed a crazy
deal i told you when you're reaching
yeah it's like whenever you do an
accomplishment they come right they come
like oh you don't even like y'all i'm
like
so what 10 years ago she probably didn't
who gives a [ __ ] she didn't know yo
gotti she didn't she was a fan
she was a music consumer
voicing her opinion voice to her opinion
and then fi but you know what be so
crazy about them old sweets
they will only dig up the negative ones
ten years ago she probably could have
said [ __ ] yo gotti and then seven years
later she kind of said yo gotti the
hardest rapper out right now some [ __ ]
but they're not gonna show you that part
they gonna show you that hey she said
[ __ ] yo got it 10 years ago and it's
crazy